The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today,
the general theme
is going to be to
try to understand
how bacteria find food.
And in particular, how do they
know which direction to swim?
How do they swim
given that they're
operating in this low
Reynolds number regime
that you read about
maybe last night?
What did you guys think of the
life in low Reynolds number?
Yeah, it's kind of fun.
You very much get the
impression that you
are kind of there in that
lecture hall with him.
They do say that some
essential arm waving was not
reproduced or so, right?
But you kind of imagine his
arms waving as he talks,
even though you don't
get to hear him talk.
So that's fun.
And it's a surprising
number of typos
given that-- every time I
read that, I'm like, somehow
this is still the best
version that I've been able
find of that talk.
But I think it's just
a neat example of how
clearly a talented physicist
can kind of from a naive
perspective say interesting
things about the way
that life has to work.
Now today, so we will
be talking indeed
about how bacteria are swimming.
But we want to
start by just making
sure we understand something
about how diffusion works,
what life is like in this
low Reynolds number regime.
And for these sorts of problems,
it's really very, very valuable
if you can just apply some
simple dimensional analysis
ideas.
And so we're going to practice
that in a few different cases,
that dimension analysis can
often tell you a great deal.
In many cases, you can
discover new physical laws.
You can figure out how
things have to scale.
And in some cases, the
scalings are rather surprising.
And given some of
the constraints
that microscopic life is facing
in this low Reynolds number
regime where diffusion is very
important, viscous forces are
dominating over these
inertial forces,
it really constrains what
bacteria, for example,
are able to do.
And it really
constrains how they
have to go about solving
the challenges of life.
So what I want to do
is start by thinking
about just a very kind of simple
situation, which is we have in,
we'll say water, a
non-permeable membrane that
is separating two compartments.
Whereas over here, we have maybe
salt or something on the right.
So this is a salty solution.
And this is pure water.
Now, this is a
non-permeable membrane.
So it doesn't allow
the salt to cross.
But the question
is, what happens
if I puncture, and I put a
little hole in the membrane
of some radius a, let's say?
Now, the question is, what will
be the flow rate, the net flow,
of salt, in this case,
from the right to the left?
All right, so first of all,
can somebody kind of answer
at least for a couple-- what
are possible things that
might be relevant if we're
going to try to figure this out?
What quantities will we
need to know or measure?
AUDIENCE: Concentration.
PROFESSOR: Concentration
seems relevant, yeah.
And in this case, there's
only one concentration.
Because well, this
conservation is
0 here, and some
concentration c over here.
What else might we need to know?
AUDIENCE: Pore size.
PROFESSOR: The
pore size, perfect.
We'll use a as the
radius of the pore.
And is that going to do it?
AUDIENCE: You need a
time for something.
PROFESSOR: We need a time.
Because what we want is
some number of molecules
per unit time that is going
to be crossing from the right
to the left.
So we need something
that has a time.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The diffusivity.
PROFESSOR: All right,
the diffusivity.
So D, so we'll say D, which
is the diffusion coefficient.
How many S's?
All right, now other things
that might be relevant?
AUDIENCE: Temperature
PROFESSOR: Temperature, OK.
AUDIENCE: I guess it's probably
going to be incorporated
into the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly, right,
so indeed the flow rate
will be dependent
upon the temperature.
But the way that that manifests
is by doing what to D?
In general, if we go up
to higher temperature,
how will D change?
AUDIENCE: Should get bigger.
PROFESSOR: Should
get bigger, yeah,
so indeed, D will be typically
given by this Einstein
relation of kT over gamma.
We'll talk more about
this in a little bit.
But for now, let's just
say that D is something
that we've measured.
Now, other things that may
enter into the expression?
All right, so this
is pretty simple.
We have three things.
Now, the question is, if we
double the size of the pore,
i.e. if we double a, how
does the flow rate change?
So we'll go ahead and do a
vote, since we like to do this.
All right, so we double a.
The flow goes up by what factor?
All right, maybe not all.
All right, and if you
think it's something else,
you can splay your cards out.
Now, the idea here is that
using dimensional analysis,
we should be able
to figure this out.
Now, I'll give you just a minute
to try to think through this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right,
so you don't even
need to know this in principle.
I'm going to give you
something else that may help.
AUDIENCE: Will it be by x?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this is
the mean squared distance
that something will diffuse.
So I wasn't
explaining, because I
was sort of-- a
hint in the sense
that in case you might
remember something
like an equation like-- Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are we doing this
at the very beginning of--
PROFESSOR: Yes,
right, OK, so there's
going to be some question
of timescales here.
OK, so it's really that
after you puncture the hole,
very rapidly it's
going to assume
some kind of steady state.
And then the flow rate will be
constant for some rather long
time.
But then eventually the
concentration on this half
will decrease.
So we're thinking
about the flow rate
after you've reached
that steady state,
but before you've
equilibrated across the two
sides of the tube.
All right, do you
need more time?
All right, let's go ahead
and see where we are.
Ready-- three, two, one.
All right, so we have a
pretty good agreement.
It seems that it's D.
But didn't I tell you
how to do the problem already?
OK, so it's not--
AUDIENCE: So the
naive thing, I guess,
would be C. Because--
oh, sorry, never mind.
Except for-- [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All
right, so I'm going
to give you another--
collaborate with a neighbor.
And I'll tell you that
it's not D to nudge you
in the right direction.
So spend a minute.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: All right, let's
go ahead and reconvene.
All right, I just want
to see where we are now.
So if you still believe it's
D despite my telling you
that I don't think it's
D, you can still vote D,
and then we can argue about it.
And that's fine, too.
All right, ready--
three, two, one.
OK, so now there's maybe a
disagreement between A and C
now.
All right, well,
nobody liked my root 2?
Maybe you saw me hesitate a
little bit before I wrote it.
I was like, oh, let
me throw in a root.
So indeed the flow rate
does not scale as the area.
It only scales with a linear
dimension of this hole.
This is weird, which is
why everybody says D.
And even after you've
done this problem,
you still think it's
D in your intuition.
But you have to like pound
that intuition away from you.
We'll try to understand
in multiple different ways
why this might be.
But what I want to
do first is just
make sure that we understand
from dimensional analysis
why this has to be the case.
Now, the first thing you need
to know for dimensional analysis
is the units of your answer.
We're looking for
something that is
going to be units, some
number of molecules over time.
Number-- there's no
units attached to that.
So the answer is supposed
to be just 1 over time.
Indeed, this is why
we needed something
that had some unit
of time somewhere
in order to get an answer
that could possibly do this.
And indeed, we know that
the diffusion coefficient
has units of, for example,
microns squared per second.
So it's a length
squared over time.
Now, the one barrier
that people have
to use dimensional
analysis is because we
have trouble remembering
what the units of things are.
So if you don't
remember something
like the units of a
diffusion coefficient,
then what you have to do is
try to find some equation
in your brain where
that symbol is used.
And of course it should be
the correct use of the symbol.
So here this is
why I'm saying it.
This is essentially
the definition
of this linear
diffusion coefficient.
And from that,
you get the units.
This is just very, very common.
Something like viscosity,
impossible to remember what
the units of that thing are.
But then you just have
equations in your brain
where the viscosity enters,
and you can figure it out.
All right, so then
if you want to use
this dimensional analysis
study, just be very clear.
Write down what all
the dimensions are.
And then the answer just
comes screaming out at you
in general.
Now, we see that we want
something 1 over time.
There's only one
of these symbols
that has a time in there.
So we know exactly how
the diffusion coefficient
has to enter.
We know that the
flow is going to have
to be something
where we know that D
has to enter in there linearly.
Because if it was
any other way, then
the time would have
some weird units.
It would be time
squared or square root
of time or something.
Now, it's true that we
could in principle dream up
something crazy between
concentration and the pore size
in the sense that
if we wanted to,
we could do c times-- we could
always add a c times a cubed
or something like that.
But of course this is diffusion.
What that means is that these
are non-interacting diffusing
molecules.
That means that if we double
the number of the molecules
over on the right
hand side, we have
to double the flow rate in
this diffusion equation.
And for diffusion,
these molecules
are not interacting at all.
They don't see each other.
And that means if you just
double the concentration
on the right, you have
to double the flow rate.
So that means we know that it
has to show up as a single c.
And all we're left with is
going to be one unit of length
that we have to get rid of.
Now, this is not, of course,
a rigorous definition.
And does this have to be
actually an equal sign?
No, so what we can
actually say is that it
has to be proportional to this.
But actually just from
dimensional analysis
and this idea of,
say, superposition
of the concentrations,
you can get
something that's really kind
of a deep statement about how
diffusion is going to operate.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It seems to me
that we can break that.
There's this degeneracy.
We can't quite sort out the
powers of c and a, right?
PROFESSOR: Right, so that's
what I was saying, that just
from the units alone, we could
always add a c times a cubed,
or to some power.
And that's why I'm
saying that you
have to be able to invoke
this idea that if you
double the concentration
of the salt on the right,
you'll double the flow rate.
Because these are
non-interacting molecules.
Because they're just
diffusing around in solution.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say that if we simply
chose the measure of flow in
90 units of number of atoms,
but in units of
mass per unit time,
and concentration in units
of mass per unit time,
then we would clearly see
what power of c it would be.
And it would have to be 1.
PROFESSOR: It's an
interesting-- I think
I'm going to disagree with you.
But I want to make sure
that I-- so you want to say,
OK, you're entering.
Yeah, the diffusion
coefficient is about what
the molecule is doing.
So I'm not sure how we're
going to-- if we measure
concentration in units
of, you're saying,
mgs per mil of some protein, or
so, then you're really saying
that there's some mass density.
And I guess you can always
define diffusion coefficient,
even from the standpoint
of-- because we don't even
need numbers.
We can measure some
fluorescence or something
of how it diffuses across.
So that doesn't require numbers.
Yeah, I'm trying
to think if this
is going to end up being
different from the argument.
I'd have to--
AUDIENCE: If we put in
the number of molecules,
then it's going to have to be
number of molecules per time.
And then c has to be linear.
Because c is number of
molecules per something, right?
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah, you could,
say, treat molecules as a unit.
And then that also ends up
requiring that it's-- yeah, no,
I think that's fair.
But I'd have to think about
this, how it would play out
if you try to measure things in
terms of mass per unit volume.
Of course, you should be able
to calculate this explicitly,
and then also to figure out what
the proportionality constant
is.
But indeed, what you find
is that it scales linearly
with the radius instead
of as the area, which is,
I think, very surprising.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We can also say D
scales with a squared times
flow.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're saying
that maybe the concentration is
not relevant.
AUDIENCE: If we look at it
that way, then the answer is D.
PROFESSOR: OK,
what you're saying
is that maybe somehow
the flow is just equal
to or proportional.
It goes as D times a
squared in the sense
that you would say that--
AUDIENCE: Over.
Over.
PROFESSOR: Right, I think that
this non-interacting particle
business really does tell
you that the flow has
to be proportional
to the concentration.
And yeah, I think that
is sufficient already.
I agree that just from
units, you could do this.
But I think, well, it's not
true, and it's nonsensical.
And it's not proportional to c.
Let's move on.
But I think it's
important that it's
possible to say something
that's a deep kind
of physical principle just
based on analysis of the units.
And then, of
course, can somebody
offer the intuitive explanation
for why this might be?
Why is it that it goes as
a instead of a squared?
And this is a little bit weird
given the fact that we all
check our intuition,
we all say D.
But the thing is, once
you know an answer,
you should still try to figure
out what the intuition might
have been that you missed when
you originally said D. Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, this might
not make any sense.
So say you would first think
it goes like a squared,
because the area
goes like a squared.
But then maybe the fact that
the perimeter grows like a,
and the perimeter
adds drag, maybe that
would subtract from
or cancel out any--
not necessarily make sense?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well, OK,
so I don't think that's
the intuition that I would use.
But then we have to figure
out, OK, what might be wrong?
Well first, I don't think
you can subtract an a.
But also we haven't invoked
any actual drag in the sense
that there's no sense that the
perimeter should be-- right?
All right, so this
is so mysterious
that we are-- that's fine.
So the way that I like
to think about this
is that it's not that
we're shooting bullets
at this membrane.
If we were shooting
bullets, or if these
were raindrops
coming, then indeed
it would scale as the area.
But because it's
diffusion, diffusion
operates on gradients
of concentration.
And what's happening
here is that you
get a local depletion of the
concentration at the pore.
So it's not the case that
you have concentration
c all the way until you
get to the pore, and then
all of a sudden you have
a linear gradient of c
across that little pore,
but rather that you
have a depletion of
the concentration
as you approach the pore.
And so as you grow
the pore, you're
somehow competing with yourself.
Another way to
think about this is
to think about what happens
if we have two pores.
For example, let's
imagine that we
have this poor here of size a.
But now I'm going to add a
second pore over here far away,
same size.
What should this do to the
total flow rate, A, B, C, D, E?
I'll give you 10 seconds
to come up with an opinion.
So I'm adding a
second pore far away.
Ready?
Three, two, one-- all right,
so we're all agreeing.
And this should be 2x, again.
This is for two pores now.
We also get 2x.
This is because if the two pores
are far away from each other,
as relative to the
size of the pores,
then these are really
non-interacting in the sense
that there's none of
this depletion effect
that I was telling you about.
Whereas as we bring
these pores together,
then they start interfering
with each other.
Because they each involve
some local depletion
of the concentration.
And once that kind of depletion
area starts to overlap,
then the point is that
there is some molecule that
was diffusing.
And if you have the pores
right next to each other,
you're not going to
get twice the net flow.
Because that molecule,
it might have
diffused through the other
pore even if it-- if one pore
were not there, then
it might have diffused
through the other pore.
AUDIENCE: Can you
not think of it
as having to do with the fact
that under a random walk,
the displacement goes like
square root of the time?
So if you increase the
number of molecules
going through by the
square of the perimeter,
then actually be like
total molecule displacement
through [INAUDIBLE]
will only go linearly
in that perimeter, which
would account for the fact
that molecule is
coming back across.
PROFESSOR: Right, so it's true
that the molecules coming back
across you always
have to worry about.
But I don't see this
argument actually necessarily
in my work.
AUDIENCE: Maybe in the
case of, like [INAUDIBLE]
which doubled in size.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
Yeah, I think that
it may be connected,
although I'm not sure if
I'm sold on the argument.
Yeah, I think it's a
little bit dangerous.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you appeal
to some sort of
depletion with that.
But if you just
punctured a hole in the--
PROFESSOR: OK, and
this is why there
is this question of timescale.
Immediately after you
puncture the hole,
then the flow rate
will actually be
higher than it will be
at that steady state.
AUDIENCE: So it's
going to be a squared.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right, I think
that the flow right after you
puncture it indeed will
scale as a squared.
Because what you're
doing is you're
taking the number of
molecules across this area.
And half of them are
going to come through.
And there's just more
molecules in that area
when you first puncture it.
But that's going to equilibrate
in, whatever, a microsecond.
That'll be really fast.
Whereas in the steady
state flow rate,
that could go in
principle forever
if it's a large reservoir.
OK, so I want to move on.
But I want to make
sure that we understand
how this basic
principle allows us
to say some interesting things.
For example, there's
a related problem,
which is, how much food
could a cell possibly eat?
And can somebody
say why there might
be an upper bound on this?
AUDIENCE: There's
a point at which
you get too many nutrients
inside of the cell.
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: There's
a point at which
you get too many nutrients
inside of the cell.
PROFESSOR: Oh no, this
is a super hungry cell.
It can in principle be able to
use every glucose molecule that
came in.
AUDIENCE: No, but I'm
saying that the osmosis
of the water coming in
would pop the membrane.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK, we're
talking about osmotic effects.
OK, yeah, but we can
just say that it's
got a super tough cell wall.
So it can take,
we'll say, infinite.
I guess what I'm saying
is there's something.
Even if I invoke such a
thing, there still is a limit.
That's really what
I'm trying to say.
AUDIENCE: The concentration
of the glucose inside the cell
is a bit high.
PROFESSOR: Well, the glucose
is going to get imported.
And then it's going to
be immediately converted
into useful things.
But then still there's a limit.
There's a maximum.
This is the maximum kind of
possible nutrient uptake.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If the diffusion
is somewhat slow,
or maybe there's
[INAUDIBLE] around the cell.
PROFESSOR: OK,
right, so maybe it
could be somehow
diffusion limited.
And what's the best that
a cell could possibly
do in this regard?
So here's a cell.
And now maybe we will,
again, have it be radius a.
So this is the cell of radius a.
The best they can be,
how would you describe
that relative to diffusion?
AUDIENCE: Can you
be more specific?
AUDIENCE: Everything
that [INAUDIBLE] membrane
could be absorbed.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So that's what I was-- so the
best that it could possibly be
is a perfect absorber.
What we mean by
that is something
where the moment that a molecule
touches it, it gets imported.
Now of course, a cell is
not a perfect absorber.
But what's fascinating
is that even if it were,
then it does not
mean that it's going
to be consuming, say,
glucose at an infinite rate.
And particularly,
we can ask, well,
if we have a situation
like this where
we have a cell, a sphere of
size a, it's a perfect absorber,
how will its uptake rate
scale with its size?
In particular, if
we double a, what
is it going to do for the flow?
All right, we're going to have
10 seconds to think about this.
If we imagine a cell as a
perfect absorber, the moment
that this nutrient touches it,
it gets imported and chewed up.
The question is, how does
that maximum uptake rate
change if I double the size of
the cell, double the radius?
Are we ready?
OK, let's see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK, so now it's a bit more of
a mixture of A's, C's, D's,
although it is a majority.
We're getting a majority
C. And again, this
is, cell doubles size.
And indeed, from the standpoint
of dimensional analysis,
this is the same problem as
that pore that we just did.
Because again, it's diffusion.
We're interested in uptake.
Now, it's not flow
across a membrane.
But this is uptake
rate by the cell.
It's going to be numbers
of molecules per unit time.
Again, there's diffusion.
The concentration
is still relevant.
And so all the same
arguments apply.
And indeed, this is, again,
proportional to the radius a.
And remember, we're following
the convention of Purcell
and calling this a.
Because Reynolds numbers is
an r, and then problems arise.
Are there any questions about
why the argument is the same
here as it was there?
OK, now, there's something
interesting about this though,
which is that you can imagine
the fact that this only scales
as the radius of the cell
tells you that there's
some sense in
which we're wasting
an awful lot of
that surface area.
Because we have this
large surface area.
But it's not as good
as you would have
thought it would have been.
And what that means
is in principle,
you could have a
smaller fraction
of the area covered by a bunch
of little pores or transporters
that are kind of analogous
to this situation
that we had before with the
salt crossing the membrane.
And indeed, if you
just imagine that these
are each little absorbing
patches that are perhaps
one nanometer in
size, small, there's
an amusing calculation
you can do,
which is you can ask, well, how
is it that the-- this is now
uptake rate.
We want to know,
how is it that that
is going to change as a function
of the fraction of the surface
area that we have covered
with these transporters,
with these little perfectly
absorbing patches?
So we imagine the cell is
1 to 10 microns in size.
Now we have a bunch
of these little pores
that we're going to go on.
And of course, this is
going to saturate somewhere.
And it's going to saturate.
And as it turns out, this
goes as 4 pi D, I think.
Yeah, so the uptake
rate is actually
equal to 4 pi cDa for a sphere.
So this is the part that we
could not have figured out
from dimensional analysis.
So indeed, the uptake rate,
once we get up to-- this
is a fraction that's covered.
Once that's 1, indeed
it's going to be 4 pi cDa.
Now, the question is, how
does it behave over here?
Now, you might have
thought that it would just
be some line like that.
It's just the more of these
transporters that you have,
you just get a linear increase
in your total uptake rate.
But it turns out
that that's not true.
Because even at just
having, say, 1%,
roughly, of the surface
covered by this transporter,
you can get something like 50%
of the total maximal uptake
rate.
And that's because
these guys are not
competing with each other so
much, because they're far away.
So this curve really looks
something like-- well, OK?
Now, this is, I think,
especially interesting.
Because a cell is not trying
to import just one thing.
In principle, it's trying to
import many different things.
So you need carbon sources.
You need all sorts
of trace metals.
You need nitrogen.
So in principle, there are
many, many, many things
that a cell is trying to
get from the environment.
And by simply having
different transporters
specific to different
things-- all right,
so here are some squares
that uptake something else,
and little, I don't know,
triangles, whatever.
So you can have many, many, many
of these different transporters
on the cell surface.
And they're each
uptaking their own thing.
And kind of
surprisingly, you can
get near optimal uptake rates
of many, many different things.
I feel that I've lost you.
Somebody ask a question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this
[INAUDIBLE], is
it really proportional to the
actual surface area covered?
PROFESSOR: Right, so
this initial thing,
this increases linearly
for small areas.
Because just like
what we said before,
if you had these two little
holes in the membrane that
are far away from each other,
then they don't compete.
What that means is that you do
get an initial linear increase
here.
AUDIENCE: But I guess
my question is sort of,
how can we get that 50% of 1%?
Is there a central
calculation that you can
do to get that, or [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh no, we can do it.
Because actually, I think that
the most straightforward way
to do this is to ask,
what is the absorbing rate
of a little patch, let's
say a circular patch?
And we already figured
out that when--
so these are very
related problems,
as you can kind of see.
I just don't remember
whether it's 2 pi
or if it's 4 pi for
that particular problem.
Because this is some uptake
of a patch, we'll say.
It's going to be either
1, 2 or 4 pi Dca.
But there's some uptake
rate from each patch.
But then that means just
that the uptake total
for small numbers
is indeed just going
to be equal to the
number of patches
or transporters times the
uptake rate of each one.
Because they're just not
competing against each other.
And the striking thing is that
because of this difference
in scaling between the
radius and the area,
this can give you a
lot of uptake rate
while only occupying a
small fraction of the area.
This is a fraction
of area covered.
Do you see why that
ends up being the case?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So that's also saying
that [INAUDIBLE] pretty soon.
PROFESSOR: Well, it depends
on what you mean by soon.
I mean, it's soon on the
scale of the amount of area.
But it could be that you can
have 1,000 of them or so,
right?
So the way I would
think about it
is that you don't
have to cover up
very much of the
cell surface in order
to get really good
uptake kinetics.
Now, these are some, say,
fundamental limits to the way
that bacteria, for
example, and other cells
can uptake food and
other nutrients.
But from the
standpoint of trying
to find where the
nutrients are better,
what you need to
be able to do is
you need to be able to
measure the concentration.
Now, the basic way that you
could, for example, measure
a concentration of something,
the best that you could do,
is if you're a
perfect absorber, you
uptake molecules at this rate.
And then you count the
number of molecules
that you uptake
over some time t.
Indeed, the number that
you uptake over some time t
will just be given by this.
What will be the distribution
of these numbers?
I should just have somewhere
up on the side always
a bunch of probability
distributions
that we can vote on.
But think about it for a
moment, and then we'll vote.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
What is going to
be the probability
distribution of the number
of these things absorbed
over some time?
Right, it's going to
be distributed Poisson.
What is going to be the
distribution of times
between successive
absorption events?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right, yeah, that is going
to end up being exponential.
And this is all confusing.
So this is a Poisson process.
These things are occurring at
random times, at some rate.
And if you have such a
process that's random,
and you ask, how many
events over some time t,
that is the definition
of a Poisson.
If this is a large number, then
the probability distribution
is going to look
like something else.
What is it going to look like?
Ready, three, two, one.
Most people are
trying to find the D,
the central limit theorem there.
What is going to determine the
resolution of that measurement
that we make?
So in some ways, what you
would like to know is, well,
what's the standard
deviation in your measurement
of the concentration divided
by the concentration?
So this is maybe
a fractional error
in your measurement
of the concentration.
Do you guys
understand why this is
the error in the measurement?
Well, this actually will go
as the standard deviation
in our measurement of the
number divided by the number
that we measure.
What's going to be the standard
deviation of this number?
AUDIENCE: The scale--
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The mean,
yeah, so it's close to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's the
square root of the mean number.
What that means is that
this thing is going to be
the square root of a 4 pi cDaT.
And this is just 4 pi cDaT.
The number that
you measure here,
the number that you uptake
over some time period
t, that's going to be
distributed as a Poisson.
And in a Poisson,
the variance is
equal to the mean, which means
the standard deviation, which
is the square root
of the variance.
It's going to be this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm not understanding
the first step where
you changed the c [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so from
the standpoint of the cell,
what the cell is doing is
it's counting the number
of these things that have come.
And it's true that from
that number of, say,
molecules that are absorbed,
to get a concentration of units
of number per cubic
micron and whatnot,
the cell would need to
know kind of how big it
is, what the diffusion
coefficient is, and so forth.
But in terms of the
fractional error,
those all end up disappearing.
Because the fractional
error is telling us,
well, if this time I measure it,
and I get 10, and next time I
measure it I get 20,
then this is telling us
about how much error.
This is indeed just
the fractional error
in our measurement
of the concentration,
and irrespective
of whether the cell
is able to estimate
the concentration
units of a physical quantity.
Because that sort of error
would scale together.
I'm worried that I'm
not helping you, though.
AUDIENCE: So you're kind of
saying because c and n are
linearly related, any
proportionality factors
would cancel out.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Would I
be right to think
that since n is distributed
as a Poisson, so is c?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
our estimate of c
would be-- because
ultimately, what the cell
would do is it would
measure some number.
And then it would
say, all right, well,
I multiply by all these things.
And then that
results in an error
in c that is distributed in
the same way as the error in n.
But they're kind of
proportional to each other.
AUDIENCE: What
has me confused is
I'm thinking that c is
Poisson distributed,
and then our original ratio
that we want, sigma of c over c,
should be 1 over square root of
c, because c is Poisson itself.
But then that's different
from what we got.
PROFESSOR: Sure, OK, I
think we have to be careful.
So it's not that the c is
actually Poisson distributed.
Because it's really that you
take a Poisson distribution
and multiply it by something
to get an estimate of c.
But if you take a
Poisson distribution
and you multiply
the numbers by 10,
then it's no longer a
Poisson distribution.
Because the mean goes up
by 10, but the variance
goes up by 100.
So then the variance no
longer equals the mean,
so it's not a Poisson anymore.
So you can't just multiply a
number times a Poisson to get--
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
PROFESSOR: And this
expression kind of
makes sense in that the
longer that the cell measures,
the less error there is.
If there's more
diffusion or higher
concentration-- less error.
And this is really in
some ways some estimate
of the best the cell could do.
And surprisingly, cells
can get close to this.
Now, this is a measurement
of the concentration
for a perfectly absorbing
sphere as a cell.
Now, you might ask, well,
how would our error change
if instead of
absorbing the molecules
we simply had a detector?
So they just asked, OK, each
time that a molecule bounces
against my cell, I count one?
Do you understand
the difference?
So this is for a
perfect absorber.
So what about a perfect monitor?
And the question there
is, does a perfect monitor
do better or worse than
a perfect detector?
So we'll say, better,
worse, or no change.
And it's of course
not possible for you
to actually do this calculation.
But it's useful to
imagine the situation
and make your best guess--
better, worse, and same.
I'll give you 5, 10
seconds to think about it.
Because it's interesting
to imagine the situation.
All right, let's see where we
are-- ready, three, two, one.
Oh, we have a fair
range of answers.
All right, I think
everybody agrees
it's going to do something.
Because it would be
kind of a coincidence
if it didn't change things.
Can I get somebody
to volunteer what
their neighbor is thinking?
I know you didn't actually
talk to your neighbor yet.
But you can still invoke that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I don't
know about this so much.
But the first thing
I was thinking
is that maybe this monitor
might be encountered on
at a different rate
proportional to its area.
It seemed like it wouldn't
change the concentration
gradient, because it
wouldn't be subtracting any.
And so then things
would bounce off of it,
and that would be
proportional to its area.
PROFESSOR: OK,
that's interesting.
So you're arguing for
a different scaling.
And then it would actually be
either-- depending on the area,
then it would be different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so that
seemed weird to me,
which is why I wanted to just
check where other people were
on that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
no, that's fair.
That's fair.
In the end, the
scaling is the same.
Although this is very
complicated, confusing.
Can I hear somebody else
argue for one or the other?
Because he actually
argued for both.
AUDIENCE: I just thought if it's
not taking up the molecules,
then it could bounce against
the same molecule several times.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
therefore, so which
one are you arguing for?
AUDIENCE: For worse.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, for worse, OK.
Yeah, and indeed, it
does end up being worse.
And it's actually
significantly worse.
It's something like
10 times worse.
And I think the intuitive
explanation is indeed
what you just said, that a
perfect monitor, that's great.
Except for the fact that
it's counting every time
that something hits.
But then it doesn't know if it
already counted that molecule
or not.
So then there's
extra uncertainty
that results from that.
Of course, ultimately, you have
to go and do the calculation
if you want to be convinced
of something like this.
But indeed, the perfect
absorber is the best
that you can possibly do.
AUDIENCE: Unless it tagged
the molecule [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Right, so that's equivalent
to being a perfect absorber,
right?
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Well, no, because then-- oh.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because these
are non-interacting molecules.
So if you tag it green,
then all that you
do is when the green
molecule comes back, you say,
I'm going to ignore that.
But then that's equivalent to
if you had just absorbed it.
AUDIENCE: But there's
no local depletion.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's
But because these are all
non-interacting particles,
then it can't make a difference.
And I agree that
this is confusing.
But I'm pretty confident
what I said is true.
Because since they're
all non-interacting,
there's just no more
information there.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what
exactly is the error?
PROFESSOR: Right,
OK, this is asking,
over some period of time, I
count the number of molecules
that hit me or that I absorb,
and then I say, OK, well, I
think that I counted 20.
And the question
is really, well,
if I did this again, how
close to 20 would I get?
Would I get, again, 20 or 21, or
would I next time get 10 or 50?
And that's the real question.
How repeatable are
my measurements?
So if I plot a histogram
of a bunch of numbers
that I get over this time-- this
is the frequency that I observe
a particular number of molecules
over some period of time t.
I get some histogram.
And this is telling us about
the width of that histogram
relative to the mean.
Now let's imagine
that you're the cell,
and you calculated
the concentration
in a really wonderful way.
Now, the question
is, do you know where
you should go to get more food?
No, right?
So you know the concentration
at your location.
But what you need to know for
that purpose is a gradient.
And I'm trying to
remember, in this paper,
they maybe are
not very explicit.
Why is it that a
bacterial cell might
do this biased random walk
that's described in the paper
instead of just
measure the gradient?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because
cell size is so small.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
bacteria are just small,
I think this is the
argument that we often give.
And that's just saying that if
you want to measure a gradient,
then what you would do is, if
you have a sphere like this,
you might say, OK,
I'm going to count
the number of the molecules
that hit me over here,
and I'm going to compare that
to the number of molecules
that hit me over there.
So you get two measurements
of concentration.
But then in order to get a
gradient, what's relevant
is you have to look
at this distance.
And of course if you
have a bigger cell, then
a given gradient shows
up as a larger difference
in concentration, or
a large difference
in the number of molecules
that are going to hit the cell.
And does that scale linearly
or quadratically with a?
AUDIENCE: Linearly?
PROFESSOR: Linearly--
difference in concentration
is going to be equal to the
size of the cell, maybe 2a,
times dc/dx.
So there's some gradient
that's out there.
And then so we get a linear
amplification of our signal
based on the size of the cell.
So if you look at
many eukaryotic cells,
for example Dicty and
others, they indeed
often do this direct
gradient measurement.
And then from that,
they decide where to go.
Bacteria, on the
other hand, they
do this other thing that's
described in the paper where
they have a biased random walk.
We're going to be talking much
more about this and the gene
network that allows cells
to do it on Tuesday.
But the basic idea
is that the bacteria,
they're swimming in
some random direction.
And then instead of directly
measuring the concentration
as dc/dx, which you might
do as a eukaryotic cell,
instead what they measure is
the change in concentration
with respect to time.
Because they are moving.
So they ask, are
things getting better?
Are they getting worse?
If things are getting
better, you keep on going.
worse, then you
randomize your direction,
and you try again.
And this implements
a biased random walk.
We'll talk about the
decision making circuit
in the cell that allows
it to do that on Tuesday.
But that's the
basic notion there.
And can someone
remind us, how long
is a typical run for E. coli?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
maybe 30 microns.
So there's this idea
that a cell might
go like this for 30 microns.
And it takes about a
second for it to do that.
But then that's a run.
But then it'll engage in
some random tumble that
leads it to go some
other direction, and then
another tumble, and then it kind
of goes a different direction,
and so forth.
So these are runs and tumbles.
Now, the nice thing
here is that you
can see that to measure this
concentration over here,
the change of concentration
across the cell
went as a, which might only be
1 or 2 microns, whereas here
now the E. coli can measure
a change in a concentration
over tens of microns.
So it's in some ways like a
longer antenna that allows it
to pick up the signal better.
There's a comment
about what happens here
in the sense that if you
imagine you have a cell,
it's a few microns in size,
flagella is pushing it,
it's going at 30
microns per second.
The question is,
if at some time it
stops spinning its flagellum,
how far will it coast?
And this is after
stopping swimming.
OK, so we'll do an approximate,
so 10 micron maybe.
How many microns does a cell
coast after it stops swimming?
AUDIENCE: This is
a bacterial cell?
PROFESSOR: This is
a bacterial cell.
This is E. coli, and this is,
we'll say, 3 microns in size.
Ready-- three, two, one.
All right, OK, so everybody
says-- and is this actually the
right answer?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, it's not.
So this is the
closest, it's true.
But none of these
things are true.
So how far does it coast?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah, so
it's some ridiculous-- I mean,
and this is really,
really weird.
This guy-- 30 microns a second.
So this is 10 times its
body length every second.
It's really shooting along.
But the moment that it stops
swimming, it stops moving.
So it's none of these things.
It was 1 angstrom or
less than an angstrom?
AUDIENCE: 0.1.
PROFESSOR: OK, 0.1
angstroms, which this is
10 to the minus five microns.
OK, so it's orders
of magnitude smaller
than you would ever imagine.
And that's because our intuition
comes from kind of our length
scales where if I were
swimming this fast,
I would keep on drifting
after I stopped swimming.
But that's not the world
that bacteria live in.
And that's because of
the low Reynolds number.
The Reynolds number is
much, much less than 1.
So this thing is the
dimensionless number
that quantifies the relative
importance of inertial forces
to viscous forces.
Now there was some
discussion of the Reynolds
number in your reading.
I maybe won't get into
too much detail about it.
But what I'll say
is that if anybody
wants to talk about a way of
thinking about the Reynolds
number, maybe you can
ask me after class,
and I can explain to you why
this weird expression can
be thought of as the ratio of
the inertial to viscous forces.
But I want to think
a little bit more
about the strategy that
these cells are following,
which is, why is it that a
run is of the length scale
that it is?
In particular, why
not go further?
We already said that its
ability to measure concentration
is somehow-- if you did
a direct measurement,
it would scale with
the size of the cell.
In this case, it sort of scales
like the length of the run.
So why not run for
10 times longer,
100 times longer, so you can
get a really good measurement
of a gradient?
AUDIENCE: Because if
you're going the wrong way,
then you'd go 10 times longer.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
it could be just
if you're going the wrong way.
Although then we
could maybe even
be just more sensitive in that.
Because what's striking
is that even when
it's going in the right
direction, it still tumbles.
The difference between
the run lengths
and the correct and incorrect
directions are kind of modest,
I guess.
So maybe we could come up
with a different strategy
where we say, all
right, well, if I
feel like things are getting
worse, I'll tumble quickly.
But if I feel like
things are going great,
maybe then I'll go in
the same direction,
and I'll measure that
gradient really finely
so I can get precisely
the right direction.
So I guess the
question is, is there
anything that's going
to limit how useful it
is to go swimming, even in a
good direction, in principle?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's so small that
collision with actual molecules
can randomize its
direction as it goes along,
and it sort of loses memory.
PROFESSOR: And this is a weird
thing, that not only does
diffusion act kind of in a
linear sense on the center
of mass position of
an object, but it also
acts rotationally, which means
that the cell and other objects
in liquid lose their
orientational order.
What that means is that
if this cell starts
swimming in one
direction, it's actually
the case that after
a few seconds,
it forgets where it was going.
So you can't actually
collect information
about the gradient
in that direction,
because you're actually going
in a different direction
from what you were
a few seconds ago.
This is actually a
pretty tough limitation
that these cells are facing.
On the one hand, they're
small, so it's really hard
to measure gradients.
On the other hand,
every few seconds,
they get turned around.
And if you imagine
trying to navigate
in that kind of situation,
it would be pretty hard.
Now, I want to make sure that
we understand how to figure out
what the timescale is that this
orientational order is lost in.
And again, we're going to
use dimensional analysis,
because I love it.
And I can tell that you
guys are big fans as well.
OK, so I will tell you
something that hopefully--
how much do I want to tell you?
What I'll tell you is
this, that the diffusion
coefficient for
angular fluctuations
is defined just the way it
is for diffusion coefficient
for the center of mass.
Given that, the question is,
if I have a sphere-- again,
size a-- now I want to know,
how does the typical correlation
time, the time to randomize,
randomize orientation,
how does it scale
with the radius?
So it could be that
this timescale tau
could go a to the 0.
And you should be
starting to think.
All right, do you
need more time?
All right, why don't we go
and see where the group is.
And it's OK if you've
not figured it out.
Make your best guess.
Ready-- three, two, one.
OK, so I'd say it might
be a slight majority B.
But then actually there are
fair numbers spread around.
Yeah, there's A, B,
C's, D's, and E's.
All right, maybe I'll
give you a minute
to talk to your neighbor.
And I'm just going to give
you an extra hint, which
is it's good to look at
the units of the diffusion
coefficient, which is why
I wrote this equation.
Yes, no?
You did that.
You're like, that's what we did.
Well, I'll give
you another minute.
Because I think that it's
important to work through this
at least some way mentally.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: All right, why don't
we go ahead and reconvene.
I know that you may not have had
time to fully converge on this.
But it turns out that this
actually goes as a cubed.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no one
would have guessed that.
Come on.
PROFESSOR: He's so upset.
It's the first sphere, yeah.
It's a sphere.
AUDIENCE: So it's not a ball.
[LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: I don't
know what to say.
AUDIENCE: Where's the mass?
Is the mass on the surface,
or is the mass in the middle?
Does it make a difference?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
We're in the low
Reynolds number regime.
So what that means
is that this is all
dominated by the interactions
between the object
and the fluid.
So it actually doesn't
enter into-- yeah,
mass is irrelevant.
So it doesn't scale.
That would've been a
fine question as well.
So a cubed, all
right, this is weird.
Now, of course you
can think about things
in many different ways.
But the thing that
you can see maybe
is that before, for the sort of
linear diffusion, so D linear
with respect to
time, you can see
that the difference in units
between these two diffusion
coefficients is a
factor of-- there's
a length squared difference
between those two.
And it's that length
squared that turns
this linear dependence of a
for normal linear diffusion
up to an a cubed.
Now, of course there
are other things
we can write down
that may be useful.
So remember this
D linear, Einstein
told us this is kT
over gamma linear.
So this is if we try to move it.
This tells us how
hard we have to push
to get something to move.
So this is if you apply force,
then gamma linear tells you
how fast it will move in this
low Reynolds number regime.
Now, there's a similar set of
things that we can say here.
I'm going to erase this.
So we can still
say it's actually
Einstein is just always right.
So the D rotational
again is going to be kT.
Now this is a gamma rotational.
But instead of thinking about
forces, now this is torques.
So what's relevant is that
if you apply-- oh, I already
used a tau.
OK, I'll just say, torque.
So if you apply torque, on,
say, a sphere, or this object,
then this will cause
an angular velocity,
so gamma rotational times
some omega around it.
Now, for concreteness,
if you have a sphere,
Stokes' drag tells us
this is 6 pi eta a times
v. So this thing tells
us how hard we have
to push an object in
order to make it move
some velocity if it's a sphere.
Whereas the gamma
rotational here,
this ends up being 8
pi eta a cubed omega.
So the gamma rotational
ends up being that.
So you can see that in terms
of rotational diffusion,
rotational order, objects
scale-- what do I want to say?
The scaling is slower than
you would expect somehow.
Well, the scaling here is
larger than you would expect,
whereas the scaling here is
smaller than you would expect.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Would this
be any different
for a bar-shaped bacteria?
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's
always different,
but not by very much.
So for example, this
thing, the Stokes' drag,
is only true for a sphere.
But this linear
dependence on a is
true for any of these objects.
So it's really that a is
some typical length scale.
And in particular, it's
actually the larger
of the two length scales.
So for example, if you take
a long kind of cylinder,
pipe, now you can ask, well,
now it's not isotropic anymore.
So there's going to actually
be two different gammas.
There's going to be a gamma
that we might call parallel
if you want to push
it in this direction,
and a gamma
perpendicular if you want
to push it in this direction.
What's fascinating is that if
this is something that's, say,
a nanometer in size
here but a micron here,
so an aspect ratio
of 1,000 to 1.
Still the difference between
gamma parallel and gamma
perpendicular is still
just a factor of two or so.
Because in both cases, it's
dominated by the longest
linear dimension.
So what's relevant is
this big thing, length.
So this is, again, an aspect
of the surprising nature
of the low Reynolds
number regime.
This is not true if you were a
skydiver or something, right?
But the reason is that this
longest dimension kind of
tells you how much water you're
going to be pulling with you.
What's relevant is not
the cross sectional area
that you're kind of pushing.
But rather it's
telling you how much
fluid are you kind of disturbing
along the whole length.
Are there any questions
about what I mean by this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
[INAUDIBLE] because the flow
is one different time.
So you're asking
about the time--
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're
wondering how I actually
get to a time from this.
Yeah, OK, sorry, I should
have finished this.
So let me just show
you what I meant.
So one way to
think about this is
we know that this
is where we start.
And what you could say
is, well, the typical time
to randomize, that's when
we've gone to enough time
so that change of theta squared
is, say, of order radian
squared.
So it's enough
that that's sort of
a characteristic reorientation.
So you just say, OK,
well, we're going
to set this equal to around 1.
So 2Dr times this reorientation
time tau will be around 1.
So that gives us that
the reorientation time
is going to be around-- so we
have 1/2, and then D rotation.
Now we have 8 pi
eta a cubed over kT.
Is that kT, yeah?
And actually in units-- so I
grew up in the single molecule
world where everything was
in units of piconewtons,
nanometers, and seconds.
And in those units,
we could actually
write, OK, we have a 4 pi.
kT is actually 4.1
piconewton nanometers.
So it's around 4 in these units.
And then eta is actually 10
to the minus 9 in those units.
a, for a bacteria,
is around a micron.
So it's 1,000.
But this is piconewton
nanometer second units.
So we have to do
10 to the 3 cubed.
Because a micron is 10
to the 3 nanometers.
And conveniently, 10 to the 3
to the third, 10 to the minus 9,
we can just cross these out.
We can cross the 4's out.
All right, so we get pi seconds.
Should we take the pi seriously?
No.
But the point is that it's
of order 1 to 10 seconds.
This is what you get from
such a back of the envelope
calculation.
But this is saying that
from the standpoint
of the bacterial
cell, it starts going.
And it forgets which direction
it started going over
the timescale of a few seconds.
So it's not worth
it for the cell
to actually have a run
that's longer than that.
Because it will have
lost its way anyways.
All right, what we're
going to do on Tuesday
is we're going to try
to understand something
about how bacteria use this
combination of runs and tumbles
in order to perform
these exquisitely
sensitive kind of travels
to find food sources.
If you have any questions about
anything that we talked about,
please come on up.